okay so you know the process of vision I  mean it's a lot more complicated but the  you know focusing just on the cornea so  if you look at visual conditions and  disorders a lot of them are due to the  irregularities of the shape of the  cornea so keratoconus which is a rare  disease it is actually a progressive  degenerative disease which is caused due  to in irregular shape in the cornea so  irregular that keratoconus actually  means cone-shaped cornea so okay rather  than a lens shape rather than like an  umbrella shape on it okay instead of  umbrella it's more like cocoa and then  that's what hurts the light exactly so  your light becomes completely distorted  as it enters and what you end up getting  is multiple images rather than a single  image on the back of the retina Oh  however this is a disease so it's  progressive and it's degenerative